I'm here with my great friend Kevin
O'Leary and we are in the beautiful
Muskoka is on Lake joseph' and we're
going for a little boat cruise now Kevin
you and I have a lot comment and one
thing in particular is about educating
people on money especially women in
children making sure that you could be
financially successful in the future so
tell us more about your books you know
the genesis of the whole book thing
because I'm now in my third one happened
this way I get about 10,000 emails a
month I can't read them all I pull a
hundred of them in the last week just to
get the tonality of what people are
thinking so you actually do answer back
to people oh yeah and what's that
sometimes we put them on the air
Langille area with the answers that
they're particularly good questions what
I started doing is I noticed that there
was the same 50 questions being asked of
me year in year out so I wrote them all
down I said okay I'm gonna answer these
50 questions because I get them every
year anyways and that was the beginning
of the first book and what happens I sit
down at night at 11 o'clock for the
bottle of Burgundy drink the whole thing
by one a probably one of yours craft of
course and then and then I I write and I
read it and I say this stuff is great
and I wake up in the morning look at it
again I say this stuff is [ __ ] so
writing a book was really hard work the
first one but I got better at it good
therapy yeah it was but I I answer those
questions from the real life experience
that I've had I've made many of those
mistakes myself I don't make them
anymore
I'm all about financial literacy now
because I realized at the age of five is
when you should start teaching children
about three five years old and and I've
got a whole bunch of points on how to do
that I've done it with my own kids they
understand the value of money you know
I'm not gonna be giving them any of it
when they graduate so they know they've
got a tough life that make they're got
to make their role their way but I'm
gonna pay for them till then that's what
my parents did with me and so at the end
of the day it's financial literacy is
what I write about and I care what age
you are you can always learn something
about how to be better in your
relationship with money because it sits
at the table with you to me a family is
like a business you're building a
dynasty together that's what a family is
and money is right there beside you
without it you have a very hard time
with everything that you do I think it's
very important that you give back and
you do you do your part so maybe you can
tell our viewers what it is that you do
you know what I've realized is for the
last I don't know 20 years I've been
giving to all kinds of different causes
hospitals universities charities ballets
you name it and I think what happened to
me in the last couple of years as I
started looking at it saying how do I
know this money that I'm giving away
every year is being properly used so
what I've decided to do is create my own
foundation
and so here's hitting the genesis of how
it happened I'm a huge advocate for
teenage entrepreneurs I think there are
people in life that know when they're in
grade 10 and 11 and 12 they know their
destiny is to take a risk and start a
business and I want to be there to
support them I haven't heard of anybody
doing it so that that's the focus of my
work and here's how it started last year
Maclean's magazine did an article on me
and they included a photo I took in 1970
because I've been a photographer 40
years another passion yeah I love it
it's a great hobby and I've enjoyed it
as I've traveled the world doing
television and investing globally with
O'Leary funds I always have a camera
with me
I've got 68,000 images from the go back
decades so they picked this one image
and published it of an airplane at a
show years and years ago and all of a
sudden a gallery in Vancouver called up
the author and said we'd like to sell
that in our gallery and it got me
thinking so I I just i sat down with my
partners at the CBC and Brookfield who
is a very big man from the gallery
downtown and where's Kenny in place and
I said listen I'm going to ask all the
Corbett who I met shooting Redemption II
another show
she was on one of the cast members and
she's probably one of the world's
greatest curators of photography and
she's about her own gallery so I had a
meeting with her said Flo look at this
work all them can you pick 25 images or
help me choose 25 and we'll do a photo
show brookfield gave up the space for
free the CBC is gonna promote it we're
gonna sell the prints for $6,000 each
they're archival II built by Charles Chu
they're printed and then the Gilder
which is legendary and making frames is
going to make these artesian handmade
frames beautify we've sold our first
three to a corporation this morning I
can't give their name out because
there's a house and it wasn't over yep
we're still getting the Intel though
yeah I know I'm very excited about it
because we're gonna launch this and make
it public on October 8th we're gonna
have a huge show at a reception at the
gallery and then we'll start selling the
prints and all of that all the profits
of that endeavor go to teenage
entrepreneurs so I hope we do millions
in sales and we're gonna take the show
to every Canadian city and major cities
in the United States over the next three
years that's my big initiative in
philanthropy I'm very excited about it
and it hits right where I care
teenage entrepreneurs so if you're a
teenager entrepreneur out there and you
want $25,000 from me go to the CBC
website enter you have to have your
teacher enter you then you have to put a
three-minute video up there and
everybody can vote I'm gonna take one
boy one girl every year and they can do
whatever they want with that $25,000
that we're just gonna grow it from there
so we'll make sure that we tweet that
out and put that on our Facebook as well
and push that out it would be great and
as soon as the CBC is ready and they
turn that site on I'm gonna be asking
everybody to push traffic there so it'll
be great
well Kevin I'm a huge fan you have been
very successful but I think you've done
it you've made your mistakes as you
admit but now what you're trying to do
is you're helping everybody else not to
make those same mistakes and the fact
that you take the time to give back and
every opportunities think of a way in
which you can do that
it says an awful lot about you well
thank you I really appreciate that and
what what you do in real estate is
probably in all the asset classes the
most important in this sense people buy
real estate with debt and if they do it
right it can be a fantastic experience
but if they get it wrong it can wipe
them out and so understanding real
estate and mortgages and debt and
maintaining yourself with that is
paramount it is the most important thing
anybody can work on so I applaud you for
that work you're doing and I think if
you keep that theme of financial
literacy going you can't go wrong
because most Canadians have the majority
of their wealth in their home so I think
you and I can cause lots of trouble I
can't wait to do and along with producer
Jake there that's holding that camera so
I think at this particular point in time
I think we need to go back and have some
fun of your place let's go open up some
fantastical Larry wine I have just the
bottle for you guys well toast to this
gorgeous day and all the real estate on
this Lake and by the way I don't think
there's any mortgages here all right
you